[موسيقى]
ايام حبيبتي
هو بسوريا احسن حاجه بيقرا من ورقه
والاكسنت بتاعته واقعه شويه مع ان انا لو
كنت وقفت شويه كويس في ضبطت نفسك في النصف
وقلت هاي طبعا ما نمسح من صحيح
بقى ايه
هو الكلام مهم في اللي انا ركز معايا مع
ان الشخص اللي اتكلم في الاول ما كانش سيء
قوي احنا
عشان كده احنا البري بتاعنا بيعمل ايه
بيعمل بيني وبين الشخص اللي بيتكلم
[موسيقى]
بس انا شايف ان هو مش احسن حاجه انا انا
شايفه بيتكلم لا بطريقه مش اللي هي وهو ده
اللي كان دي
بيكاسونج
انت محتاج تدي اللي حوالين فرصه علشان
هتعرف فعلا تطلع اللي عنده لانك في درب
هنا هتكون فعلا بياخذ فرصه بيقف
فيها بس زي ما احنا بنبتدي تشان
س او ان هم
حاجه ممكن تاكلها والناس كثير مش بتعملها
في الحد اللي انا باتكلم عليه هو احمد ابو
السعود احمد سعود
[موسيقى]
كبيره وبيطلع سفاجا كثير زي ما انتم
شايفين وبيلعب بس برده شخص بيستمتع حياتي
قوي
دي مش دايما بنعملها
[موسيقى]
لكن مش دائما مركز في حياتهم انجوي
اللايكات جدا بس انا
مخليني عايز
اتكلم في مره كنا بنراجع ابلكيشن بتاعه
فقلت له احمد
انا حاسس ان الابلكيشن مش احسن حاجه محتاج
ين شكرا
تعرفني انت اصلا تسافر اليوم اوكي ونحاول
قال لي انا عايز اتعامل معه في الساتش
كويسه عايز انزل واجي من البيت وحدي عايز
اركب باص براحتي باللحظه ان احمد كان من
اصحاب الامام لا تنطبق عليه كلمه واعطيه
كده انا باطبق عليها لكن هو فعلا ما عندوش
اي باريس موجوده بمشيش الفكره ان الرساله
دي اللي مجرد ان انا على وشيء انا ما
اقدرش اعمل كذا وكذا وكذا ولو قدرت ادخل
الفرقه انا كده عملت اكبر انجاز
الموجوده احمد معلش هي اصلا مش موجوده قدر
الازاز هو انا شفت له فيديو وهو بيبوس
كثير جدا رابط جديد التمر الصغيرين بعض
ولا لسه عايش في يده بيحرك نصف اسمه اي
طريقه مختلفه هو فعلا قدر
مش بس لان هو عنده
حاجه مختلفه بدنيا لكن لان هو فعلا المايك
او 2 وما عندوش اي مشكله فيها فخلينا نجرب
ازاي فعلا الحاجات دي بتاثر على تفكيرنا
وعلينا عارفين جمع توصل لما فتحت ابوابها
حاجات كتير تقدم وانا فكرت ساعتها ادرس مع
السويس رحت قلت خلاص خلينا نقدم فكان
معايا واحد صاحبي مش هاقول على اسمه عشان
معظم الناس انا تعرفهوش شويه
فاحنا واحنا بنقدم وباقول لكم هنقدم في
اليوتيوب
فراح بس هي كده تمام من تحت خالص هات لي
اسوء جامعه
[موسيقى]
فوق شويه فانا تمام فقلت له هنقدم اي اقصر
ابصر انت بتتكلم
حماس عادي يعني انا لسه متخرجين قلت له اه
انا لسه في حاجه هو رفض فمك لازم يكون
كبير كده عشان اقنعه بقى رحت لو فاضي ايدي
كده وقفت في الكونر تروق احمد
توفيق اي هم اللي جاب لهم احسن مننا في
ايه خلينا قبل ما خلينا نجرب طالما ان
احنا مش هننفع حاجه فيها فروحنا ساعتها
قدمنا
وبعد شويه الايميل لان احنا جايين لنا
اكسنت جامعه
لو انت مجدي يعقوب هو هيحدك يعمل بيه ايه
هو عايز يبدا يعلمك فاول حاجه ان احنا فهم
تا اصلا ثاني حاجه ما تجرب انت هتخسر ايه
انا هاعرف ناس كثير
لما اجي اسالها على حاجه باي باي تبعد عن
جامعه
تصدق نفسك
انت لو ما اخذتش الرزق دلوقتي
عندك 100 سنه
[موسيقى]
فانا مهندس معماري ويقال عندي شويه
بحث كويس وانا مش حافظ جدول الضرب لانهم
يعني
مش عارف اقول ايه بعد الناس اللي موجوده
[موسيقى]
يعني اللي مش موجوده زيها ليه اعشيها جدول
الضرب
ليه اتعلم القسمه المطوره ثلاث صفحات مع
ان انا ممكن اعمله
المجموعه الشمسيه ودينا بناخذها ايفينش
يبقى انا خلصت طبعا يعني ههه
بس ده من خلال
الاكس بس لما جينا نتعلم المجموعه الشمسيه
ما كانش في حاجه اسمها الساوند ماركت
فينوس اللي هو اعترضه وماشيين السكه دي لا
هي التيتشر جابت لنا شويه حور وقالت لنا
دي اسمها الشمس
بتاعتها كذا وبتديت هذا لازم تكون بعيده
عن كذا وكوكب فينوس اللي هو الزهره اللي
هو مش اول واحد جنب الشمس لكن هو اسخن من
اول واحد جنب الشمس عشان الناس
شعره
بطريقه مختلفه
والجرب ثاني ما تدينا هندي صغير
فهمنا المجموعه الشمسيه بتشتغل ازاي مش
فتحه عن طريق ان انت اللي بتشتغل ده مش
انت مجرد فكره
الحاجه الثانيه ان احنا نتعلم على الصدر
هي من الشمس
طلبوا مننا ان احنا نجيب البيتزا بعد
سلسله طبعا عارف البيتزا
الاكشن هو مش عامله اكل بنعمل ايه
باكوين في
الشارع يعني فجبنا ساعتها العلب دي واروح
حاطينه الفويل عكس بعض ما تنساش انضغط على
الفيديو وحطينا فيها شويه عجينه
معنا في الموضوع انك تكون لطيف عشان الناس
السبب منك المعلومه مستفيد الفراغ اللي
احنا كنا لسه صغيرين
علبه
سبسكرايب قوي
لغايه ما اخذنا احنا كمان كل واحد بيعمل
زيها طبعا العجينه ما استوتش لكن اللي
فعلا الحاجه اللي استوت هي الاي دي اللي
كانت في دماغنا
اسمها صودا الايموجي فهنا النجس ممكن يطلع
منها حاجه مفيده فهمت ان انا ممكن اطور
احط مرايه مكان الفويل
هيفتك مثلا
احسن عشان كده انا ما بحبش الاسد تقول
في مجموعه فدائي عشان ادخل فدائي فدائيه
عشان الناس تقول عليها الناس مش هتعيش معك
اوكي انت لما تاخذ كريم على سبيل المثالي
المهندس او طبيب وبتشتغل في مجال كذا او
بتشتغل 36 ساعه في بيقول اما يجي على
الدكر انت انت اللي فكرتش انت مجرد من
الشيش وراء الاراء الثانيه لازم انت فعلا
تشوف انت عايز تعمل ايه
من اسود الفترات اللي عشتها في حياتي هي
كانت فتره الكوكو
بس من افضل الخطوات اللي اتعلمت فيها برده
وابتديت فيها اشتغل على فكره براءه
الاختراع الكمبوسه
ودي حاجه كبيره لدرجه الحراره
من السنين الارض ده بيبقى تحت الميه الارض
مش هتروح اي حته لكن احنا اللي مش هنبقى
نازلين العيش المره الثانيه واديكم دلوقت
[موسيقى]
ضحيه انها مساله تدفع ثمن حسيت ان في شويه
سوشي ان احنا لازم اعمل حاجه
[موسيقى]
طب خلينا نعمل حاجه مفيده لو دفعت الثقيله
وما نفعتش انا ما خسرتش حاجه
جربت اشتغلت بقى
على توصيلات بتاعته
[موسيقى]
احاول احاول من غير ما يقاس وكل مره
يفرقعك بتبقى اعلى من اللي قبل ده كان
دائما الاشاره
[موسيقى]
دي فكرت ان انا ايه اكلم واحد صاحبي كان
سعودي
كذا امتحان
بس احنا يعني احنا كده بس مش هتنزليه لان
احنا مهندسين معماريين مش ناسيين كهرباء
قلت له وادينا هنجرب والوضع هتغير لما
ترضي بيه بعدين ان هي كانت بتسرق عشيه
وحدي كانت بتفرقع فينا احنا الاثنين دي
والثانيه بقى بس احنا
نجرب انا فاكر واحنا بنتجرب واحده منهم
فهو انا عمال
ولا لا
[موسيقى]
الموت فضلنا نجرب وفي الاخر ما نفعتش في
اللحظه دي اعلنت خلاص استسلام ان انا ما
فيش حاجه في ثاني انا فعلا حاولت وجربت بس
هي مش مش راكبه يعني انت كلمنتي بقى مع
بعض كذا كذا كذا قولي ودي بتبقى فائده انك
تدي صفوت لحالها قال لي انا هاخرج جدا انا
مش محتاج ان انت توصل الهزارس انت فعلا
عملت انت لازم هتشتغل بعديك هتعرف ان احمد
حسن في واحد اثنين ثلاثه لحد 10 وهيكتب له
رقم 11 انت فهمت في حاجه مش شرط انك اخترع
الزمن انت قولي لي خلاص عملت اللي عليك
وانا هاديك على كلمه قلت خلاص انا الصعيدي
وفعلا كلامه مؤثر معه ودوله بقى الطازج
الاصدقاء فعلا هيلين اللي بتكون نظرته
الايجابيه تكلمت تلميذ رحت قلت لها ان انا
عملت كده وفشلت خلاص هو هيكلف بتاع مصر
وهو بيطلع جنبه فشل 10,000 مره ثانيه بس
معلش معلش انا لقيت 10,000 طريقه ومش
انا
لقيت ب 10.000 واشتغل
ت برقم 1001 ومعلومات عن انك مش بتياس
للدرجه قلت لها لا انا فعلا هاجرب لكن انت
قاعد لوحدك مش وراك حاجه العالم كله واقف
الج
ره
اتكلمت في الفصل بتاعي وقلت له فعلا لو
عايز تساعدني وصلني ادرس حطي لي معك سوفت
كذا وكذا ويكونوا بيدعمنا بس انا عادي
تمام خلاص انا هاوصلها كمان
على بدايه الجهاز
كويسه ومحاول اعمل
ازاي شغال على علاج واحده انت مش عارف انا
قاعد في شقتك الصغيره
[موسيقى]
عملت البتاع ده وزي اللي انتم شايفين
الاتصالات درجه الحراره بدل ما بقت بتنزل
بقت بتاعنا اخترعت الجهاز بيضر الناس اسرع
بيموت الناس اسرع بيسخن الفراغات كان نفسي
بالضبط زي
وحسيت ان كل حاجه خلاص قفلت بس قلت خلاص
بس شعرك افتكرت الكلام ده انا قاعد مش مش
هاعمل حاجه وافتكرت ان انا رامز
[موسيقى]
بعد نزلت 12 درجه
72% 78% معنى كده ان الناس طبعا سواء
فاتوره الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
الحاجه اشتغلت وانا بتاخد فكره وحشه عن
نفسي لا حسيت ان دائما بتجيء لي فكره
المجنون يجيب العالم ده لو النهار وبينا
كلنا قاعدين كده ده شويه همم صحراء هيكون
عندكيش اقول لهم يا جماعه انا هاقدر اعمل
لكم كذا انا اقدر اكتب بيتزا انا اقدر ان
انتم تكييف فانا اقدر اعمل كذا مش اصله
مجرد عايش حاله مع القطيع هيختاروا حد
ويفضل نعمل الحاجه دي فده كان بالنسبه
للسنه الكبير بس بقى عندنا مشكله
[موسيقى]
كبيره كده في اللحظه دي هاقعد بس الفاتح
الزوج
[موسيقى]
بس انا عايز اشوف الناس عايزه
قد ايه انا عملت بقى ايه ده سوري
[موسيقى]
على اليوتيوب شويه
واتعلم شويه الجرافيكس ورحت قررت ان انا
اعمل نفسي طبعا صلاه نفسي في كاميرا
الموبايل وانا انزلها علشان اتاك كاني
باتكلم من الاستوديو علشان بس الناس تدي
اهتمام شويه وكله يركز طب هو عاملها ازاي
وخليت السلايت كلها بتجيء على الجزء اللي
وراء طبعا المنظر الحقيقي الجنسيه جدا كنت
حاطط كل الاباجورات في وشي وتتحطط برينس 3
وكنت حاطط الموبايل على الشاشات وخاصه
اللي هي التحديا جبت الصغير بيعمل بالكلام
عشان انا احفظه لانه ما كنتش اقدر احفظ
حاجه سانتفق بالمنظر ده بتدي
فعلا اضرب ان ما فيش اي نقص
في بس حاجه اللي قالها ورسمت في الفيلم
بتاعه الجديد اللي هو بيقول ان فيه فضول
ده جميل كان في داون الناس اللي مش هتقدر
تعمل حاجه هتخليك تقتنع انها ما ينفعش علم
حاجه كده
واحده عايزه تسوق جديد فتقول لصاحبتها
النيجاتيف طبعا تقول لها انا بابا الثاني
العربيه بتاعته فانا هانزل اتعلم عليها
السواقه وهنزل امشي مثلا
[موسيقى]
كامل
نعملها في المدرسه
[موسيقى]
وبعدين اليوم
الصغيرين كل واحد فاز اكبر منه وبيقول
بيخبط على على اليوتيوب
بتاعك علشان المستقبل
[موسيقى]
بيوت اخر الشارع احنا لسه ما سالنهمش
تعالى نسالهم وانا طويل العريض كاشش كده
ورق البيوت والبنت الصغيره شايفاني
اكسرها انا محددها لي ومعانا الاطفال
وفضلت تخبط فبتقول لهم ان احنا عايزين
نزرع الشجره دي في الباكيو بتاعكم علشان
احنا بنفرد فاين تشيز واوينز وعماله تحكي
لها وبعدين
ما تقتنعش قوي براحتك
[موسيقى]
شويه حاجات ولا ان هم شويه شهادات
الموضوع ده يعني احنا زرعنا في مسلسل
مش مجرد زينا كثير ان احنا
حد يعمل حاجه
نفسها لما تتغير
تقدر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]